ouah frédéric viale merci à d'autres
avec nous en direct sur rt française on
peut le dernier dîner de travail ce soir
pour un gala merkel et emmanuel macron
tout d'abord que retenez-vous de ce
couple franco allemand
en réalité le couple franco allemand
n'existe pas ça va peut-être vous
sembler étrange ce que je dis mais
normalement dans un couple il ya une
certaine égalité cdmm parité en fait
dans un véritable couple or là ce qui se
passe depuis beaucoup d'années et bien
avant même l'élection de maquereaux
c'est que l'allemagne domine très
largement dans l'union européenne et
domine très largement la france et ça ça
vient du fait que nos élites politiques
et administratives en tous les cas en
france sont totalement énamouré du
modèle allemand et coll constamment à la
roue de ce que veulent et de ce que
exige en réalité les allemands et donc à
partir de là il y a une véritable
domination
de l'allemagne à l'intérieur de l'union
européenne et dans ce pseudo couple
franco allemand qui fait qu' on peut
dire aujourd'hui que non ce n'est pas
réellement des relations paritaire des
relations égalitaires c'est
véritablement une façon de faire des
élites politiques françaises qui
consiste à coller constamment vers la
politique allemand pas spécialement liés
si on vous comprend bien au couple
macron merkel mais intrinsèquement
finalement au couple franco allemand et
ça depuis plusieurs années oui bien
d'autrui vous avez excellemment bien
compris c'est à dire que c'est bien
avant macron c'est vraiment structurel
depuis en réalité au moins la création
de l'euro pour tout un tas de raisons
l'euro a été taillée
comme le souhaitait l'allemagne de
l'époque et globalement on a un euro qui
facilite les excédents commerciaux
structurel de là et les excédents
commerciaux structurel de l'allemagne se
tombe ce sont les déficits commerciaux
de la france aussi largement en partie
en tous les cas et cela la france aucun
président depuis chirac n'a voulu
remettre ça en cause et n'a voulu mettre
ce problème là sur la table à partir de
là on a véritablement des relations très
très inégalitaire et c'est finalement ce
qui s'est passé le couple entre merkel
et makro ça n'a pas tellement
d'importance en réalité leur relation
personnelle puisque elles sont
totalement déterminées par la structure
même des relations franco allemande
angela merkel va donc laisser sa place
fin septembre après seize années au
pouvoir
quel bilan tirer de ces mandats dans son
rapport quand même avec avec la france
l'allemagne a réussi à exporter sa
politique au redoux libéral et à
l'imposer d'une certaine façon à la
france enfin quand je dis à l'imposer
nos élites bureaucratiques et politique
étaient bien d'accord pour ça bon mais
en tous les cas la politique
de faible coût des salaires de faible
coût du travail a été largement importée
vers la france et le résultat tout ça
c'est qu'on a des politiques osterrieth
air y compris en france qui se
poursuivent alors que ce sont des
politiques qui sont fondamentalement
inefficace économiquement et injustes
socialement ça veut dire si on suit
votre raisonnement que quel que soit le
futur dirigeant allemand ça ne va rien
changer sur cette relation déséquilibrée
oui les chances que ça ne change pas
sauf si il y à un prochain dirigeant
français qui à l'élection européenne
ce pardon l'élection présidentielle
excusez moi soit capable de remettre en
cause
pseudo couple franco-allemand est de
mettre un certain nombre de problèmes
sur la table notamment celui d'aider des
excédents commerciaux considérables de
l'allemagne et que aigle et ça ça
voudrait dire un changement de politique
extérieure de la france et ça serait
très très important de discuter de cela
dans l'élection présidentielle
évidemment ça veut dire nécessairement
un futur président ou présidente
souverainiste dans ce cas le seulement
ils aiment s'affranchir silence et
encore une fois votre logique
si on suit ma logique oui absolument
c'est à dire que bon ça c'est pas secret
mais effectivement je pense que la
retrouver la souveraineté de la france
pour une essayer de faire en sorte
qu'elle se reconstruise est absolument
nécessaire et c'est l'enjeu de la
prochaine élection présidentielle la
prochaine élection présidentielle c'est
pas l'enjeu identitaire c'est parce que
raconte zemmour c'est parce que raconte
l'extrême droite l'âge est le véritable
enjeu c'est pour la france de recouvrer
sa souveraineté merci beaucoup et où
frédéric viale un spécialiste des
questions européennes merci d'avoir aidé
ray avec nous à voir porter votre
analyse